put him
Vladimir Putin walks into tumultuous
Applause they've been waiting a long
time and it is bitterly cold from the
president a rallying cry for their men
at the front and for Unity
cheers
[Music]
India
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
people had been pouring in since morning
many from State companies even though it
was never officially confirmed the
president would show and just outside
the stadium the buses they came in on
row upon row of them
it is extraordinary that an event the
president may or may not attend and
which we can't get accreditation for
even days before manages to attract tens
of thousands of people hours before he's
even rumored to show up it really speaks
to the power of the state Machinery
working away in the background how do
you feel about sort of being told to
come to an event that then shown on
State tv as a Great Patriotic moment
um
[Music]
foreign
bikers club who's known to ride with
Putin
I wish you to get rid of the American
yolk he tells me
the U.S president was having a meeting
in Warsaw at that moment with countries
who'd shaken off the Soviet Yoke the
Bucharest nine they're called now NATO's
Eastern flank
thank you well in Moscow earlier in the
day Vladimir Putin had met with China's
top Diplomat Wang Yi at the end of his
European tour as questions swirl over
China's intentions and whether it might
move to support Russia militarily
back in the stadium extraordinary scenes
children the West would say were
abducted by Russia from the streets of
bombed out mariupal here described as
rescued the soldier who took them 367 in
all fated and these are touching scenes
it speaks to the way that both sides see
this terrible War through a glass Darkly
with little chance on either side that
sentiments will change
Donna McNay Sky News Moscow